SYSTEM AND DISABLED THE FLIGHT
INFORMATION FEATURE ON ITS
WEBSITE.
BRET?
>> Bret: JONATHAN, THANK YOU.
FORMER INDIANA GOVERNOR AND
CURRENT PRESIDENT OF PURDUE
UNIVERSITY, MITCH DANIELS, HAS
SOME THINGS TO SAY ABOUT THE USE
AND ABUSE OF TECHNOLOGY AND BIG
DATA.
HE HAS JUST WRITTEN AN OP ED IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" TITLED
"SOMEONE IS WATCHING YOU".
HE JOINS US TONIGHT FROM PURDUE
UNIVERSITY IN WEST LAFAYETTE,
INDIANA.
GOVERNOR, THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
WHY WRITE THIS OP ED?
>> IT WAS SOMETHING OF A
SURPRISE TO US, BRET, HERE HOW
MUCH WE KNEW ABOUT OUR STUDENTS
AND WE'RE BEGINNING TO DISCOVER
WAYS WE CAN USE IT FOR THEIR
BENEFIT.
WE WANT TO DO THAT.
LET THEM KNOW THINGS THAT WOULD
BE -- THAT CORRELATE WITH
ACADEMIC SUCCESS AND THEY'RE
PROGRESSING BETTER HERE AT
PURDUE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, WE CAN
TELL THERE COULD BE MISUSES OF
THAT SORT OF DATA AND I WROTE IT
JUST BECAUSE I KNOW THERE ARE
INSTITUTIONS OF ALL KINDS WHO
ARE NOW IN POSSESSION OF
INFORMATION IN ENORMOUS
QUANTITYS AND WE'RE ALL GOING TO
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS TO ASK ABOUT
OURSELVES ABOUT MAKING SURE WE
DO THE RIGHT THING SXNT THE
WRONG THING WITH IT.
>> Bret: THAT LINE BETWEEN
PRIVACY AND WHAT YOU COULD USE
WITH THAT DATA, OBVIOUSLY, IS
SOMETHING WE DEAL WITH.
IN THIS OP ED, YOU SAID PEOPLE
SERENE IN THEIR ASSURANCE THAT
THEY KNOW WHAT IS BEST FOR
OTHERS, HAVE TO STOP AND ASK
THEMSELVES ON WHAT AUTHORITY
THEY BECAME THE NUDGERS AND
GREAT APPROVEERS.
MANY OF US WILL HAVE TO STOP AND
ASK WHETHER OUR GOOD INTENTIONS
ARE CARRYING US PAST BOUNDARIES
ARE PRIVACY AND INDIVIDUAL
AUTONOMY SHOULD STILL PREVAIL.
I MEAN, THAT IS IN FACT, NOT
ONLY ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES BUT
WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH WITH
THESE BIG TECH COMPANIES AND
WHAT THEY KNOW ABOUT ALL OF US.
>> AND IN GOVERNMENT AND IN MANY
OTHER WALKS OF LIFE.
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE AND IT
ALWAYS, OF COURSE, IS MOTIVATED
BY WHAT THEY BELIEVE ARE GOOD
INTENTIONS WHO THINK THEY KNOW
WHAT'S BEST FOR OTHERS.
AND ARMED WITH THE -- THESE
MOUNTAINS OF NEW INFORMATION,
THEY WILL BE DISCOVERING
PATTERNS THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO
ENCOURAGE OTHERS TO FOLLOW THAT
PRODUCE WHAT IN THE NUDGER'S EYE
IS A GOOD RESULT.
SO THIS IS SOMETHING I THINK TO
BE CAREFUL ABOUT.
THERE'S SOMEWHERE, AS I SAY,
BETWEEN HELPING A STRUGGLING
STUDENT, IDENTIFYING A
STRUGGLING STUDENT AND
CONNECTING THEM WITH A TUTOR.
AND REALLY SHOVING PEOPLE INTO
BEHAVIORS THAT SOMEBODY HAS
DECIDED ARE -- ARE PREFERABLE.
THERE'S A LINE.
AND WE OUGHT TO BE -- WE OUGHT
TO BE DEBATING IT IN INDIVIDUAL
INSTITUTIONS AND COLLECTIVELY.
>> Bret: I WANT TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ABOUT A COUPLE OF
THINGS.
ONE IS WE'RE GETTING READY FOR
THIS TESTIMONY UP ON CAPITOL
HILL.
CONGRESS WITH THE BIG TECH
COMPANIES, Facebook, GOOGLE,
TESTIFYING BEFORE CONGRESS.
AND THERE'S REALLY CONSIDERATION
ABOUT REGULATIONS.
WHERE DO YOU THINK THAT GOES?
>> WELL, HE ALWAYS GOT TO
REGULATE WITH GREAT, GREAT
CAUTION AND THOUGHT.
BUT THIS MAY BE AN AREA.
THERE ARE CERTAIN, YOU KNOW,
CERTAINLY ANTITRUST AND THE
SUSPICION OF BUSINESS IS NOT
WITHOUT ITS FOUNDATION IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
AND WE HAVE SET UP VARIOUS
BOUNDARIES BEYOND WHICH WE DON'T
THINK INSTITUTIONS SHOULD --
SHOULD GROW AND SPRAWL.
AND IT'S HARD NOT TO NOTICE THE
INCREDIBLE CONCENTRATION IN THAT
INDUSTRY.
IT HAS ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES AND
NOW WE KNOW IT HAS MAJOR
SOCIETAL CONSEQUENCE WHEN'S THAT
MUCH INFORMATION IS IN THAT FEW
HANDS.
>> Bret: TWO MORE THINGS.
ONE IS YOU'RE HISTORICALLY A BIG
DEFICIT HAWK.
SOMEBODY WHO IS CONCERNED ABOUT
THE DEFICIT AND DEBT FOR A LONG
TIME.
YOU TALKED ABOUT IT.
JUST BEEN THROUGH THIS WHOLE
OMNIBUS SPENDING ISSUE.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT
AND WHERE THE COUNTRY IS
HEADING?
>> I'M VERY TROUBLED.
YOU KNOW, IT SHOULDN'T ESCAPE
PEOPLE'S NOTICE THERE WAS
MASSIVE AMOUNT OF THE
DISCUSSION, DEBATE AND THERE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ABOUT A TAX
BILL THAT MAY OVER 10 YEARS
INCREASE THE DEFICIT BY A
TRILLION DOLLARS.
NOT TO BE SNEEZED AT.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE ALREADY AT $20
TRILLION, IT'S ONLY THE
PERCENTAGE THAT IT IS.
RIGHT ON ITS HEELS, CONGRESS
HAPPILY AND CHEERFULLY PASSED A
$2 TRILLION ADDITION TO
SPENDING.
YOU KNOW, WE FINALLY FOUND
SOMETHING PEOPLE THERE CAN GET
TOGETHER ON.
AND COMPROMISE ON.
BUT IT WAS PROBABLY THE WRONG
THING.
AND THE LOOMING DEBT THAT WE
HAVE BUILT IS AN ECONOMIC
MENACE, BIGGEST ONE TO THIS
COUNTRY IN THE OPINION OF MANY
OF US.
AND TO OUR FUTURE PROSPERITY,
IT'S ALSO -- WITHOUT QUESTION, A
MORAL DUBIOUS THING TO DUMP ON
THE NEXT GENERATION, BILLS NOT
FOR MONEY THAT WAS BORROWED AND
INVESTED IN THEIR FUTURE BUT FOR
MANY THAT THEIR ELDERS BORROWED
AND SPENT ON THEMSELVES.
AND, YOU KNOW, THE PROBLEM HERE,
BRET, IS I KEEP TELLING PEOPLE,
THE CAN IS GETTING HEAVIER.
AND WE'RE RUNNING OUT OF ROAD.
>> Bret: AND QUICKLY, THIS
WEEKEND IS THE NCAA FINAL FOUR.
CONDALEEZA RICE HAS BEEN ASKED
TO HEAD UP A COMMITTEE LOOKING
AT THE NCAA BASKETBALL AND SOME
OF THE PROBLEMS THEY'VE BEEN
HAVING.
YOU'VE WRITTEN ABOUT THAT AS
WELL.
YOUR THOUGHTS AS WE HEAD INTO
THIS WEEKEND?
>> IT'S A LITTLE LIKE THE BIG
DATA COLUMN.
I'M ALL QUESTIONS AND VERY FEW
ANSWERS.
THE ONE THING I KNOW AND THINK
IS VERY HARD TO ARGUE WITH IS
THE STATUS QUO IN DIVISION ONE
BASKETBALL NEEDS A LOT OF
REPAIR.
WE'VE SEEN CORRUPTION.
WE'VE SEEN THE GAME, IN ESSENCE,
SEMIPROFESSIONALIZED ALTHOUGH
THE PEOPLE, THE YOUNG MEN WHO
ARE CREATING ALL THE VALUE DON'T
GET PAID FOR IT.
AND SOMETHING REALLY NEEDS TO
CHANGE.
I'M SO GLAD THAT THE NCAA HAS
ACTED AND COMMISSIONED A GROUP
LED BY SOMEONE LIKE CONDI RICE
WITH HER TREMENDOUS JUDGMENT AND
CREDIBILITY.
AND SOME OTHER GOOD PEOPLE ON
THERE.
IN THE COLUMN, I THREW OUT THREE
IDEAS.
BUT THEY'RE PROBABLY THE WRONG
I DON'T PRETEND TO KNOW THE
EXACT ANSWER.
BUT WE NEED TO REINSTATE THE --
THE ERA REALLY OF GENUINE
STUDENT ATHLETES AND THOSE WHO
ARE REALLY ONLY ATTENDING
COLLEGE TO PURSUE AN ATHLETIC
CAREER AND PRETENDING TO BE
STUDENTS WITH THE COME
STUDENTS WITH THE COPL
STUDENTS WITH THE COPLIC
STUDENTS WITH THE COPLICIT
STUDENTS WITH THE COPLICIT O
STUDENTS WITH THE COPLICIT OF
THE INSTITUTIONS OUGHT TO BE
PAID ABOVE THE TABLE IN SOME
SORT OF MINOR LEAGUE, IN MY
OPINION.
LOOKING FORWARD TO A GREAT
TOURNAMENT
TOURNAMEN
TOURNAMENT.
FOUR GREAT TEAMS THERE THIS
WEEKEND.
ALL CREDIT TO THEM.
THE SYSTEM AS A WHOLE SHOULD NOT
GO ON AS IT IS MUCH LONGER.
>> Bret: GOVERNOR DANIELS, WE